now I know you already know all about
Lamborghini in its cars so I'm just
gonna jump right in with this
Lamborghinis 2016 Huracan Spyder is so
wrong and so right
this is the $267,000 drop-top version of
the Huracan coup it has the same v10 602
horsepower engine with the same
all-wheel-drive top speed is about the
same to 201 miles per hour with a zero
to 60 to sprint time of 3.4 seconds what
is not the same as the thrill factor
this Huracan has that open top which
goes down in 18 seconds and which makes
it way more thrilling to drive and you
are going to want to drive this thing
there is no rolling around corners no
lumbering up hills zero hesitation when
you press the gas I drove the spider
along the Pacific Coast Highway near Los
Angeles working through its three drive
modes and using its paddle shifters on
an incredibly perfect 7-speed
transmission now sadly there is no
manual option the steering is the most
precise I've ever felt one flick of the
wrist and you're off and the brakes are
perfect with no fading and total control
driving it is a rare treat so this is
the spider version of the Huracan that
we saw last year and the main thing that
Lamborghini wants you to know is that it
is the same car which is saying a lot
for a convertible with this spider you
don't sacrifice anything in terms of
performance the top speed is the same as
in the coupe you know and sacrifice
nimbleness steering handling and braking
performance it's all the exact same it
feels like the exact same car to drive
the only difference is open air
the car is made from a superlight and
hybrid aluminum carbon fiber frame that
keeps it to 3400 pounds this is a feat
of engineering that gives it speed and
precision but be warned this thing
almost sits on the pavement there is a
lift kit which adds about two inches off
the ground but navigating speed bumps in
this thing nearly gave me an ulcer
there is no back seat and no Headroom
when you put that soft top up
I love the minimal interior of the car
with its cockpit like toggle switches
red-painted starter button and the helix
like dashboard but not everyone will
feel the same the seats don't really
adjust and the cup holder cost extra you
can choose a clear glass engine cover
special rims carbon fiber packaging and
a rainbow of hues for the massive
ceramic brake calipers and it's true
this car looks amazing it might be my
favorite modern Lamborghini to date with
the LED lights on it looks like a
monster coming for you at full speed
just watch out for those potholes